ترامب يعلن ترشحه لرئاسه امريكا ويفتح
النار على بايرن مفاجاه تتكشف عن صاحب
واقعه محل الكشري لسان رونالدو قد يغرمه
اكثر من مليون جنيه استرليني هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا
بكم
بعد ساعات من الرعب خيمت على اوروبا
والعالم اثر قصف صاروخيا غامض استهدف
الاراضي الفولانديه ووجهت خلاله اصابع
الاتهام الى روسيا خرج الرئيس الامريكي
جوبادل لازاله الغموض مبلغا حلفا النيته
والشركاء في مجموعه السمع الكبار ان
الصاروخ اطلقته الدفاعات الجويه من جانبها
رحبت موسكو بضبط النفس الامريكي في
الحادثه التي اوقعت قتيلين وكادت تتسبب في
تفاقم التوترات بين روسيا وحلف النيته بعد
مطالبات بتفعيل المادتين الرابعه والخامسه
من معاهده الحجز
وفي امريكا ايضا اعلن الرئيس السابق جمعه
ترامب ترشحه رسميا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقرره في عام 2024 وفي خطاب استمر لنحو
ساعه تحدث ترامب الى المئات من انصاره عن
ابرز انجازاته خلال فتره ولايته وجهها
سهام الانتقاد للرئيس الحالي جوبايدن
وادارته محملا اياه اخطاء الانسحاب العاجل
من افغانستان و فاتوره التضخم وتراجع قوه
امريكا خاصه في ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ومن جهته رد سريعا رئيس بيض على
نبا اعلان الترشح هذا بالقول ان الرئيس
الجمهوريه السابق خذل بلاده خلال فتره حكم
وبعد غياب لنصف قرن اطلقت وكاله الفضاء
الامريكيه ناصر مهمه المركبه ارتميس واحد
غير الماهوله الى القمر في اعقاب تاثيرات
عده لعمليه الاطلاق بسبب مشكله فنيه وسوء
الاحوال الجويه وتعتبر المهمه الجديده
خطوه لناسا نحو اعاده اكتشاف القمر في
رحله ستستمر 25 يوما تهدف للتحقق من ان
المركبه الجديده امنه للنقل طواقم بشريه
الى القمر مستقبلا
والى مصر مازال عامل النظافه صاحب واقعه
الطرد الشهيره من احد محلات الكشري يتصدر
التراند حيث كشفت مصادر امنيه عن اخلاء
سبيله بعد ضبطه لاستكمال اجراءات حول
اتهامه في واقعتي قتل الخطا وتبديد نفقه
وكان عامل النظافه اثار عاصفه من الجوده
خلال فتره الماضيه بعد طرده من مطعم شهير
لمنعه من تناول الطعام في الصلاه الداخليه
ثم طرده مره اخرى من موقع لتصوير احد
الاعمال التلفزيونيه
وسطهامات من البعض باستغلاله لاثاره
الجنوب
وفي خبرنا الاخير يبدو ان التصريحات
التلفزيونيه للنجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو مهاجم مانشستر يونايتد التي هاجم
فيها اداره فريقه ومديره الفني لم تمر
مرور الكرام حيث كشفت وسائل الاعلام ان
اداره الفريق الانجليزيه تدرس تغريمه
رونالدو نحو مليون جنيه استرليني جراء
تصريحاته العاصفه خلال المقابله التي تركت
اللاعبين الكبار في اول ترافورد غاضبين